hi so today I want to talk to you a
little bit about the two laws of coding
that I've learned during my PhD Journey
so I've spent a few years learning how
to code over my academic career and
definitely at the beginning I found
coding really really hard especially
because I come from physics and I think
theoretical physics at the beginning at
least when I was studying wasn't really
doing much coding so the first project I
had to make I still remember really
vividly was this project in C++ trying
to cat up the three body problem and for
me it really seemed like magic and I
didn't know where to start or how people
learned the syntax or how people came up
with good solutions to these kind of
problems and I think today this has
actually changed a lot nowadays people
can just learn how to code online and I
think actually you don't really need to
go to university to learn how to code
most programmers that I know and really
respect that are super good programmers
they've mostly learned it by themselves
by trying to work on their own type of
projects so the first thing I always
encourage people that want to learn how
to program to do is to program through
Project based learning and I talk about
this before but I think Project based
learning is truly the only way to learn
how to code and that's because when you
take a course for example on corsera you
mostly learn the synx but you will stay
quite beginner if you only stick to
learning through these courses and
that's because learning how to program
is not only learning the language of
programming but also the thinking of
programming and the thinking of
programming in my regard is a bit more
similar to how for example a scientist
works or how an engineer works so you
get a novel problem and you really try
to think through first principles to the
solution and I think this type of skill
you cannot really learn unless you work
through problems yourself and on top of
that just what I've seen is that when
people pick projects that they actually
truly enjoy and find really important
they just spend a lot more time trying
to work through these problems so one
way you can learn python for example is
through this course called H 100 days to
code and this is not sponsored or
anything but I truly enjoy this course
and I think it's a really good way to
Learn Python because every day you work
through a different problem set and at
the end of the course you will work
through your own projects and this is
really projects based uh learning tool
another thing you can do is to explore
cackle competitions I know a lot of
people really enjoy these type of
competitions and you can definitely get
a lot of experience out of it and lastly
you can also of course start on code
academy they have a lot of these smaller
projects that you can work on but again
I would definitely recommend you to try
to think of your own projects as well so
for example one of the first projects
that I built was this Pomodoro Timer cuz
I personally use Pomodoro timers a lot
but but I wanted one with a cuter
background and another one was this like
Financial app that like kind of tracked
my finances cuz I thought that would be
super useful so something else that I've
enjoyed is that a lot of programmers are
on Twitter and they kind of show their
work there and what they do is these
small 30-day challenges so I would
definitely also recommend to follow some
of your favorite programmers on Twitter
and kind of see what they're up to
because I think these challenges of
trying to finish a project in 30 days
really worked at least for me to
motivate myself to try to finish
something to the best of my capabilities
and that kind of brings me to the second
point and that's to really truly Embrace
failure and to embrace the uncertainty
that you will feel through coding so I
definitely know at the beginning when I
started to learn how to code I mostly
took courses and that's kind of because
they felt more safe and that's
especially because there were some
answers online on how to solve different
problems but in the real world if you're
trying to learn how to be a programmer
or you want to work on some code for
your PhD there are no solutions for your
problems and I think actually through
the struggle of trying to find a
solution or come up with your own
solution you will become a much better
programmer but the fact of the matter is
that sometimes for me for example it
takes almost 3 months to come up with a
good clear solution to a project or to a
problem that I'm working on and I think
this struggle you cannot really learn
unless you go through it yourself but
the patience you learn through working
through projects and kind of embracing
the uncertainty and the failure is
definitely something that I think is
very valuable and that most programmers
that I know that are really good
programmers have so for example a lot of
my friends are working on deep learning
problems right now and these different
type of autoencoders and I know one of
my friends has spent almost two years
trying to optimize an auto encoder to a
work as she wanted too and I think if
you start programming you probably
cannot even imagine working on the same
project for 2 years but if you slowly
build up your patience with failure and
your capability to understand
uncertainty you will be able to make
these larger projects and also probably
publish it maybe at a certain time or
work at a company that needs you to be
able to work on these larger type of
problems so this was a super short video
but if you have any tips for me on how
you improved your coding or what kind of
courses online you enjoyed I would love
to know so please put it down in the
comments below and next week I want to
make a video on how to write a paper a
lot faster cuz that's something that I'm
working on currently so if you have any
questions towards that also let me know
and otherwise see you next week bye